it's just like
it's fantasy football though you know
you don't like it i don't give a [ __ ]
you don't care no
aren't you
no you know you don't play fantasy
football no really you want me to
[ __ ] tackle you and [ __ ] show you
what it is do it huh want me to [ __ ]
spear you on some [ __ ] lester
hayes [ __ ] right now jesus
do it dude you want to show you what
[ __ ] real football is
dude we'll see some lawrence taylor [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
big
boy better do it big you don't live
twice
you don't get a chance to do it again
let me show you what the thick light
feels like
thick light
big nation
[Music]
to him no more because the next thing i
do it ain't gonna be ain't gonna be
funny he's gonna be getting street as
[ __ ] bro
he got his ear bit off i know dude
the jewish tyson
what's good man
jumping into
you guys want to tell me
you're [ __ ] jumping me man
[Music]
i'm just going to give you a little
squeeze
and you were talking such a big hit see
what happened yeah there you go yeah
what do you do dude that's it
no get the full headlock
suck my [ __ ] dick [ __ ] yeah there it
is
there it is oh no no don't do it what
happened
i submitted
[Music]
you're talking so much let me rock you
like a baby i tapped well that was good
when i did yeah i got them off the other
hand
you can't do anything
with one arm
is this they don't do this in new york
fighter and the kid i was back just beat
the
[ __ ] out of brendan i didn't want to do
it but i did it in his home like in his
new studio and [ __ ] was [ __ ] up
he's doing the show of course great to
see callan great to do it with chappelle
for the first time going to be in uh san
francisco
uh this week in new york next weekend
love the fighter and the kid let's go
but i am rapport was beating him uh in
the ratings last week but i still love
fighting the kid
[Music]
i can't let myself get caught up in
their emotions i just put some eyes all
on my girl well i'm here to
um i'm here for brendan's
show um and
possibly doing a two minute
three minute set if i have that much
material
rest in peace to my brother kobe um
yeah and i'm looking forward to it i
gotta get the stage time
uh for uh cesar bros in tempe
yeah yeah
how you doing
brother thanks for coming again
we're talking money
schultz is here obviously to do time but
also to watch my 30 and give me some
notes
he's the most critical comic in the game
so
you want a guy like that combing over
your stuff
it's gonna be great you need people need
more friends like andrew schultz you
found out i'm shooting my 30s like i'll
be there i need to see it all right
so he's pulling up tonight andrew
schultz one of the best in the biz
go fast got my foot on the gas while our
hands in the air i just been floating
and staying in motion and hoping that i
don't get stuck up there
i can't let myself get caught up in
their emotions i just put some eyes all
on my girl and now she flexing she gonna
hold me down yeah that's my gang yeah
that's my best friend i just put
[Music]
so you finished laughing now you're
still listening to these other 3 000
people laughing you're like all right
let's go
what's going on you know what i mean so
like when you're in the club it's a
quicker pace
you know what is it
just it just makes more sense and then
you build the act and eventually you get
to that point where you can handle
those people man get that [ __ ] out of my
face
oh man i just did a spot on brendan's
show the haha dude was a lot of fun love
this gang love this crew you guys are
the best dallas make sure you come out
support brendan he's coming there for
some shows addison improv go check out
your boy i'm out pete this is practice
so this is our uh these are the training
days man these are training days this is
the the workout room it's the workout
room we put in the work so when you see
the finished product it's all shiny and
nice man so that's what we're doing
we're just getting reps in before we
shoot this special next week
no pressure
no pressure and these lights are sexy as
hell
what are we doing again
that was basically
a lot of people
said i'm about to put on keith sweat and
take my pants
i wanna please you
oh that's my shirt
i
[ __ ] hilarious amazing show had an
amazing time
laughing all night my girl's mexican i
was [ __ ] dying you guys gonna love
the show
there are 30 minutes of straight fire
you guys gotta go
best show you'll see
this whole year dallas texas europe
great great time ahead y'all gonna enjoy
it
one showdown friday night packed house
the fans showed the support because they
know it's crunch time because we're
shooting special next week so i'm taking
this energy i'm harnessing this energy
i'm bringing it to dallas it's been a
great night man i can't wait i can't
freaking wait
[Music]
the whole overall experience of this was
[ __ ] awesome like i gotta give a
shout out to brendan and the crew
chappelle everyone david
everyone that gave me this opportunity
because
um i'm getting back into comedy and it
this is very good it's like a workshop
for me like i'm still in the process of
like writing jokes and stuff
and so this was a perfect opportunity
for me to like just throw things and see
what sticks you know so like even
tonight you know that bit i didn't do
last night and i thought of it in the
hallway and i'm like this is a perfect
opportunity for me to at least try it
and uh so yeah i'm like
i really had a good time that that was
probably my best [ __ ] like that was the
best feeling show that last one because
the crowd was there was a lot of people
that's exactly what i needed to carry on
over to my shows in dallas i couldn't
ask for a better crowd a better night
friday night late show at the haas
sold-out crowd it was amazing time i am
so pumped for this special after that
after that from these la fans i'm ready
to go man i'm just ready to go set's
ready we got a hot 30 coming your way i
can't wait for you guys to see it love
you guys thanks for all the support
all the shows that i've done leading up
to this 30 minute special it's all for
you guys i can't wait i just can't wait
can't wait for you to see it love you
guys
[Music]
we're live
what's up dallas peeps we got a big
special weekend come up thursday friday
saturday taping on friday and saturday
dallas come on out also got a little
treat for you texans out there i got
exclusive big boy merch just for the
fans that come to the live taping it's
not gonna be on sale anywhere else ever
you have to come to the show to get it
in person it's the built collab thick
boy bro whisper special taping
[Music]
wrestle with these demons